Most people think that miscellaneous products are more difficult to eat than famous brands, poor quality or less effective.
But big brands are usually more expensive
Are there really different brands and big brands?
In terms of food, there are many companies that produce miscellaneous products.
In fact, many big brand manufacturers have spare capacity
Production of branded products in 2007, Peter Pan brand peanut butter
Was found to contain Salmonella and was recovered and destroyed
At the same time, Walmart's own brand Great Value was also removed.
The next time I go to the supermarket to buy things, compare the nutrition signs of the brand and big brand products.
Even if they don't look exactly the same, they are even identical
But you may be able to feel a little bit similar to them.
According to the study, the brand is 30% cheaper than the big brand.
In addition, many large livelihood items, like sugar or salt, are regulated by the Food and Drug Administration.
In the case of salt, it is also called sodium chloride, and its composition is only two elements on the elemental table -
How big is the difference between a brand and a big brand?
Maybe their tastes taste different? The gorgeous packaging of the product may have an impact.
In one study, college students were asked to help them test the coffee score
As a result, even if the coffee is the same, they still think of a coffee package with a beautifully wrapped sugar packet, a cream ball and a silver tray.
Better than a coffee combination in a plastic cup filled with sugar and creamer.
This illustrates the placebo effect (meaning that although the patient receives an ineffective treatment, it is expected or believed to be effective, and the symptoms of the patient are relieved.)
Greatly influenced the evaluation of coffee
But in terms of medicines, there are different brands and big brands of medicines must be the same.
For example, Ibuprofen is a non-steroidal anti-inflammatory analgesic
Used to treat headaches, fever, mild pain
Ibuprofen is also sold under the name Advil or Nurofen
Even if the name is different, the same two hundred milligrams of ibuprofen, the safety, efficacy and usage are the same.
The brand of drugs has undergone a series of tests to verify its bioequivalence with the big brands.
The only possible difference between drugs in different brands is the additives in the drug.
For example, starch, gelatin, spices and pigments
So even if the drugs are not identical, the effect is the same.
In fact, people prefer to use drugs that are branded.
Because they are usually cheaper
Of course, there are some drugs that require special doses and need to use a specific brand.
In this case, the doctor will assist
However, people still have doubts about the brand.
In one study, subjects were given a false painkiller and received a microshock
When they were told that the price of painkillers was very good, only 61% felt pain relief
But when they were told that the asking price was 2.5 yuan, 85.4 percent felt pain relief.
Finally, whether in food, medicine or otherwise
Miscellaneous cards can be, but are not absolutely identical to, big brands
So save the money and buy something special.
In the secondary channel AsapTHOUGHT
We also took another experimental film to see if everyone can judge the difference between the brand and the big brand through the trial.
Linked to the narrative column below